hi everyone
um a bit of a sensation on wednesday
with uh the news of um
the
google uh no
owned by google but it's the
alpha
zero
uh chess engine
playing against the stockfish and making
a fantastic score um
28 wins
uh and 72 draws it's
no losses against stockfish
which
i would say
was the strongest
chess engine we had
so it's a big big news
two
uh yeah
i'm not sure whether i'm rambling to
myself or if anyone is actually
listening so uh if you are listening um
give me a little chair in the comments
um
and then i'll keep keep on talking yeah
okay so we have people thank you thank
you
we have people yeah so uh we're going to
be discussing the uh alpha
zero and it's um
ten public games
uh against stockfish
um i'm really looking forward to seeing
more games um
but as of now and these uh these guys
have um
are keeping their cards close to their
chests and um
they are waiting on publishing the
their paper and what they have
discovered in some kind of fancy um
fancy magazine or whatever you call it
in the academic world
um
[Music]
so
what we have for today is um
a couple of games i'm not gonna have
time to go through all 10 games we we we
have
uh and i'm actually going to focus on
not the big
magnificent attacking chess although
that is
uh an eye-opener i think for
for a lot of people
uh but but i'm going to focus on more
the
uh strategic element
uh of al facero and how it managed to
outplay uh stockfish in a very humane
fashion
um
several times uh
during the match
um i'll also talk uh quite a bit about
what is this uh
of uh alphacero um
i'm happy to take computer questions um
but i'm not going to be able to answer
most of them uh so i'm also hoping that
we have some kind of uh discussion
um
in the chat in which i can get some
questions and somebody else somebody who
knows this stuff
uh more than me
uh can help uh answer um
yeah
i i can say a lot of uh clever things
about the chess implications uh but as
in
in terms of how this actually works
i'm
not quite certain
myself
that is not my area of expertise
what i understand is that
it has played
many many million
chess games against itself
in trying to learn the game
and trying to understand
i suppose the strategies
um
i mean i'm a grandmaster but
i i have not played through a million
chess games in my life uh so
already uh in the simulation it has a
lot more chess experience than me but on
the other hand you would think that the
games i have seen and the games i have
learned from uh
may have been
more
um thematic uh than than the the kind of
brute force learning uh learning by
doing uh method
uh
we have a comment in the chat um
vag is uh is still in denial uh he
cannot believe that stockfish lost with
such a score difference and i i i slept
in on wednesday i mean i i wasn't up
until noon and i was waking up to
essentially armageddon that this new
force had just come and
demolished
uh what was our our kind of
strongest
chess playing
entity
walnut also comments on something that's
um that's actually something i want to
bring up
and he he says it must be some kind of
hardware uh handicap
um and in fact
for sure there is um alphacero was
running on
something called tpu something
which is one of these computer things
that i have no chance of understanding
but i think essentially alpha 0 was
running on something completely insane
um
whereas
stockfish was running on um
processors i think
but part of the problem here is that
i've read somewhere that stockfish can
only do
128 processors
and after that
it's diminishing returns and after that
it doesn't actually help
anymore
okay so here's the comments helping me
out so it's tpu is a tensor processor
unit optimized for neural web networks
and of course i have no idea what neural
networks is
um
yeah so i'm going to talk a bit about um
about the chess implications uh kasper
is asking
how does it learn the the artificial
intel intelligence how does it learn
what the time control is but
that strikes me as one of
presumably one of the easier things
uh telling it that
the time control was one minute per move
and that's also an interesting fact in
terms of
understanding the the level we're
talking about
um
yeah so cesa is saying that tpus are a
bit like gpus but then you're already
overestimating my technical knowledge
because i don't know what a gpu is
um
but he's saying you could run something
like alphacero on publicly available
gpus
but it would be slower and more power
usage and this i think from a chess
perspective this is going to be one of
the main things whether or not it's not
really about whether or not
stockfish had a fair match with
uh
with alpha 0 because i think
probably we can conclude that it wasn't
really a fair match
the hardware difference uh was
quite significant but on the other hand
it's a very interesting to see an engine
going on its absolute maximum potential
and as i was saying the the stockfish
cannot kind of scale up
uh in the same fashion that um this
alpha zero could
and and what's interesting from a chess
player perspective is whether alpha 0
can scale down
equally well as what stockfish can
because stockfish i have stock fish on
my
computer
my simplest computer i can get in the
store for a couple hundred dollars i can
have stock fish and it's going to play
chess better than any human and i i
think one of the interesting things is
whether or not we can get this alpha
zero
technology which i don't really
understand how it works and whether you
can get that
down
and run it on a very ordinary
laptop computer um
let's see the comments
um
stockfish didn't have an opening book
says move by move
um
yeah al facero did not have an opening
book in traditional sense but alpha
cerro had done a lot of training games
in which it had um
kind of
decided what are the best openings so it
it had run a lot of simulations to
determine uh what its favored openings
uh would be
um
i thought stockfish had an opening book
or maybe there were was predetermined
openings because the stockfish playing
the openings without opening book
it's not very good and i i thought the
the openings uh of the games that were
published uh were
normal
and i'm not sure stock fish would be
able to play normal openings without
having some kind of opening book
jason
asks how long would one of today's
premier players survive against this new
supercomputer
um
would they be squashed in every game in
2030 moves and my answer to that is
absolutely not i mean people would still
be able to play against this
supercomputer and i think some people
have said
kind of said that this is the end of
humans
being able to to challenge the computer
uh
i i think that time had already passed
the time in which a computer could beat
that a human could beat the computer in
a game
um i think we already passed that point
but i do not believe that this uh
at the very least this version of alpha
zero that it would win every single game
against the human
that i do not believe
so so i believe that this
uh
this alpha 0 may be unbeatable
but it's not like it's going to win
every single game even against humans
they both had no opening books
which was confirmed by the developer on
twitter okay that's interesting but in
that case i also think that
stockfish playing the opening as well as
it did was was was pretty good
um this stream will be archived there
was a question that it's going to be
available on the
norwegian youtube channel maybe maybe
the the traditional chess.com channel as
well
um yeah so
an entire sleeve has the same kind of
comment i was saying that the real
question and i'm quoting the real
question is how long it will take to
bring this technology to market and and
as as a second to
a at the very least um being interested
in
in analyzing chess openings for the
world's best players i think that's
going to be
the main concern for a lot of people is
is
when and how can i use
this stuff myself
uh yeah so um
this is kind of the introduction talk uh
and now i'm gonna
uh i'm gonna have um i'm just gonna look
through some games i think uh and this
first game is um a black wing uh which
is impressive in its own right uh alpha
zero had um
three black wins
and 47 draws
in the 100 game match
um
so so we're gonna look at it and and i
think what's interesting is that alphago
having no opening book
decides that the best way to face e4
is the berlin defense
which
a lot of top players have been saying
for a couple of years now
but it's always nice to have it
confirmed
um
so
it's a berlin defense from alpha 0 but
it also shows
that you can win with black in the
berlin which i have been saying for some
time i have some nice black wins in it
um
and
and alphago proves it
so this
c3 move is is quite um
unusual
uh but we're going to
the opening is not really the most
interesting part of this game i'm gonna
gonna go a bit forward
until we get this position uh which is
really blocked uh stockfish going c4
threatening c5 pushing the bishop away
from d6 and now alpha zero goes c5
and after d5 we have a very blocked
position
now
um
i've been going through some of the
games with my own stockfish which of
course is nowhere near the level of the
stockfish that was playing the match but
i think it's interesting to kind of
uh compare uh so we also see that the
the stockfish in chess.com um
graphics
uh is saying that it's point
point 34 you can see on the on the
bottom left it's saying 0.34 uh 31 sorry
and this is just interesting from a
positional sense because that's
basically going to be stockfish in
general thinks that this is a favorable
pawn structure
a favorable position for white uh
and if you were to give this position to
a human
they would
uh say that this is one of the positions
in which stockfish might be wrong
because we will see the
uh blue wasn't really my intention
uh we will see the bishop on c8 black
having the bishop pair
and we will say that this bishop on c8
is unopposed
uh so there's potential for this bishop
to do something on the white squares
without having an enemy bishop uh
countering uh white square attacks
now the other bishop on d6 is not the
proudest piece
on the board uh it's severely blocked by
its own pawns and that is probably why
stockfish is saying that this is
favorable for white
but
this is actually known from for many
many many years uh from a famous cappa
blanca game in which this bishop on g3
is basically as inefficient as the
bishop on d6 this bishop is being
blocked by
the black pawns
and it really doesn't have
too much of a future
just like black's bishop on d6
so this is one of those very interesting
situations in which stockfish is
mis-evaluating the position it doesn't
understand the the long-term strategic
dangers
of the the opponent having the bishop
pair and the unopposed
um
a light squared bishop
um so um
so yeah i i think uh and it's also
interesting that um
alpha zero gets into this position and
kind of says
uh
okay you think this is good for for you
uh i'm happy as well
and i think
maybe
um alpha zero
is more
human in
uh positional play
and and i think at the very least we
don't know how alpha 0 evaluated this
position i can only double check what my
own version of stockfish
says
but
my impression is that it's not an
accident that alpha zero won this game
and probably it has
its
some of the holes that um stockfish has
in positional evaluations
may
be uh addressed
uh in this alpha zero
um
so yeah so i'm gonna go forward a bit uh
and
just make notice of this uh evaluation
bar on the left-hand side because it's
gonna get a little shocked when it
realizes that the white pieces aren't
really accomplishing too much
um
okay so the the
the low depth version uh we have on the
side is not really picking up on it but
this is the moment when
um my stockfish started to realize that
this isn't working out white doesn't
really have a plan white doesn't have
any good squares for his pieces he's
just standing there
waiting and
black is kind of standing there but
black is doing some progress for every
move right now black is doing uh
um
covering the
the ea e5 pawn so that you can in the
future play the pawn up to
uh
f5
so this is the the moment where where my
stockfish realize that this is just
equal
but that is also wrong that is also
wrong because black is better black is
the only one who can uh start moving
forward with his pieces
uh
and so even an equal evaluation here
from from stockfish would be
too much
so this is um
interesting from um
from an evaluation standpoint so
actually here uh black wants to play f5
but then bishop ah4
asks a question to the rook on e7 and
it will probably be a draw by repetition
so what alphago does is play
h6
and now
it creates a very strange sequence
because
white goes bishop h4 to prevent f5
black goes rook f7 preparing f5 and then
white goes back saying that if you now
play f5 i'm gonna have some attack uh
winning the pawn on e5
so they went back and forth for a little
while and then um it's alpha zero who
decides no i'm going to play on so alpha
zero repeated moves and then went out of
the repetition and the same thing
happened on the next move they repeated
moves and then in the end alphago
decides no i want to play for more
um so probably it has a decent contempt
value as well um this is
a value you can give i know that you can
give stockfish kind of a contempt value
in terms of avoiding draws whenever
possible uh and here stockfish is the
one
getting the um
the uh
the the contempt against him
uh so and now we're gonna see black uh
calmly improving his pieces uh this
bishop on d6 is not fantastic but
neither is the bishop on g3
uh the the low depth uh stockfish on the
left-hand side still thinks white is
better
but that is not going to last for long
and i think also the regrouping that
alphago does here is very very nice so
let's go back just to make sure everyone
sees that the knight started on f8 and
in a couple of moves it's gonna be in a
fantastic spot
because
gradually the knight moves over
and i think when we get
to this position
we see that
black has just been able to make so much
progress the the knight on uh d6 is
fantastic attacking both
the pawns on on c4 and e4
um
[Music]
and and even worse the bishop the bishop
that was supposed to be so bad on d6 has
come over to h6
and has a good diagonal
whereas the the white bishop is still
knocking on uh
on stone knocking on this black pawn
structure
with the pawn on e5
so um
stockfish was just massively outplayed
and still
even in this situation
he didn't really understand what was
going on so
um
my my my stockfish check with my
computer it was going minus 0.4 so
stockfish was realizing that this isn't
really the
what i was hoping for but still it
doesn't understand that in this position
i'm going to say that black is probably
uh strategically winning
um i i i think
the white pieces are basically going
back and forth and have been going back
and forth
for quite some time
uh and black does have plans to progress
he's just very good at taking his time
and that's something i noticed in some
of the other games as well is that al
facero is not in a rush he will calmly
outplay you
and he will not rush and and he will um
improve his pieces in what i actually
as as a norwegian chess commentator i've
been been used to calling it
the magnus carlsen
calm collected let's improve uh our
pieces and see what happens
and that's pretty much what what uh
what happened here
i mean black is just improving his
pieces gradually
whereas white is
is stuck
um
yeah okay now this is an interesting uh
comment from
rob stop
um he says i don't expect they
explicitly coded any contempt in alpha 0
and that's that's of course true i mean
if it's self learning then
then nobody has told it to be contempt
for to to stock fish
but but on the other hand then i think
it's strange
that he repeated moves
why would he repeat moves
it he would only repeat moves if he
thought those were the best moves right
so if he thought those were the best
moves why would he suddenly change and
go out of the repetition
um
[Music]
for good reason i might add um
afterwards why wouldn't he just go out
of the repetition immediately
i don't know
that's gonna be almost a philosophical
question
uh donks um is saying that it could be
google engineers interfering
to avoid the repetition to see who
understands the position better
uh that sounds like conspiracy theories
to me um
it could be i don't know i don't know
how this kind of stuff works
um but but i think it's an interesting
thing that there were a couple of
repetitions in which um
in which google xero played on
yeah an entire sleeve is saying that
would be academic fraud
so
it sounds sounds like a bit too much but
at the at the very least it's something
that the the google people actually
could explain
uh why it repeated moves and then
changed it its mind in what was an
identical position
yeah because like a grundiloo is um
our grandeur says the best move
is still the best move after two
repetitions
but then it's not the best move anymore
since it would allow a draw
but in that case it would be
mis-evaluating the position
to start with because
the reason they were repeating was
because with best play it was equal
yeah i don't know i i
i think we've stumbled upon something
interesting
and i don't have the answers
i'm being told to scroll up to what cert
4 says
search for
maybe it has learned
that if you repeat moves and the other
side doesn't make the right move
you gain a bigger edge
that trick
may have worked when it was playing
against itself
yeah i don't know
so you play
a move and then
if
the if your opponent plays the best move
you can go back and have another go
whereas if the opponent doesn't play the
best move
you get a better position than what you
would have got had you played
uh the move that avoided repetition in
the first place
i don't know
uh but anyhow the game the regrouping
the the outplaying of stockfish
i think is fantastic
um and i'll just do the the end of the
game to kind of show uh for completion
um the bishop uh exchanged itself
uh
taking more control over these two
squares
[Music]
interesting but at this point
even the the most
normal computers are are understanding
that this is
really really troublesome so it started
out about here uh giving minus 0.5 and
in three moves uh even my stockfish was
saying that this is a complete disaster
for white
and so what happened was that they
exchanged one pair of rooks in the g
pile
making sure that black wasn't attacking
against the white king
but then we had another rook coming
another exchange
but ultimately what happened was that
this ending is just a disaster for white
because of these
pawns on
c4 and e4 and now we see the hero of the
middle game the unopposed light squared
bishop is going to come around and start
gobbling up pawns
and that's essentially what happened
and uh at this point even my stockfish
is saying
big big big trouble
um
uh and i'm gonna
fast forward a little bit
uh in this occasion i i tried um
i tried to see if i could improve
stockfish's uh play
so i was checking the line with bishop
takes e5 uh if you take back the bishop
there's a fork
so you have to go into an end game
and i was wondering maybe
uh stockfish or
even alphacero had misevaluated
this
opposite code bishop endgame um
and after analyzing it i discovered that
no this is just winning for black but
the way it's winning for black is is um
is very instructive
and and it's kind of just
using
both sides of the board
to gradually make progress so at some
point black is going to be able to play
b4 you cannot really stop it if you take
on b4 then you undouble the black pawns
so you should sacrifice
the
your pawn on a3 and hope to make some
kind of barrier along this diagonal
but it's just very very good end game
technique here uh where you play uh
f4 at the right moment
uh the king cannot take because then the
black king is going to
help its pawn queen so we need to take
with the pawn and then we get this kind
of situation where black goes back with
his king
attacking now going for the h4 pawn
and this is
i mean it's fantastic in game play but
it's uh best move actually here there is
a zoot song you cannot protect both
the h4 pawn and the f4 pawn
because the bishop has to guard
the a1 square as well so you get back
the the original pawn you sacrificed
and then gradually you get the other
pawn
uh as well because
you get this uh check
which uh blocks the bishop from um
covering a1
and with three pawns up
then opposite colored bishops are are
not a draw
so i i tried finding some kind of
improved defense for
for stockfish but um i couldn't make it
happen
um yeah i'm gonna have to go down
uh
somebody's saying that nils's
explanation makes the most sense i'm
gonna see if i can find what nils
wrote
interesting from high leaguer bim bum is
that alpha 0 does not evaluate the
position like normal engines
it evaluates the position based on how
big the chances are to win
it does how do you know
maybe i would know as well if i knew
something about computer science
yeah i think i still think it's a bit of
a mystery i'd like to see somebody who
actually knew what was going on say
something about it
about the repetition anyway uh back to
to the game so this kind of going into
the opposite colored bishop end game
wasn't really gonna work
uh but neither was uh the way uh
stockfish ended up playing
so uh he might as well gone for the
bishop ending and we would have seen a
very nice stylistic
win in the end game whereas here
black just won the entire kingdom
because after knight a3 bishop d7 you
cannot protect a4 but more importantly
after you lose a4 you're also going to
lose
um
on c4 with the bishop coming in from
behind
so stockfish just played bishop e3 and
uh well actually we did get a bishop
same game uh
at the end uh
because in this position
uh alphago just played knight e4 and i
think with a pawn up uh
i'm not sure a human would do that but
he just knew that well this bishop
ending i'm going to win ah sorry
um
miss click
he just knew this bishop and the ending
i'm going to win so he played bishop
knight e4
uh exchanging into an opposite colored
bishop end game
um
with just a pawn more i mean he's just a
pawn up in an opposite colored bishop
ending
uh i i don't see a human making that
decision uh but he was right a fantastic
endgame player also alpha zero um
and just winning this uh
this opposite colored bishop and game
very easily uh coming with the king i
don't know if stockfish could have
defended better i i would assume so but
there's kind of the dual threat of going
with the king harassing the bishop and
the threat of the king going here
and even if white plays something like
um
king e3 king d5
you cannot kind of
sorry you cannot stop the king from
going both ways
um
yeah i'm very happy people are
discussing in the uh in the chats
but some of it is too
over my head and i i just have to admit
that
yeah
their evaluation is a win percentage and
not a score for each move
um and i was also told that it doesn't
really have the traditional algorithm i
have i understood it correctly that
alpha zero is using
monte carlo simulations from the current
positions
to decide
where to go next
i i i that's what i've been told um
and and
for that reason alone i think it's
interesting um
i i guess this technology have existed
for for some time but just the idea that
you're programming the chess engines in
a different way that what has almost
been exclusively done before is
is fantastic
so dragon vs dota is saying it's monte
carlo simulations but it's weighted by
the neural net so it's not completely
random
you lost me at neural net
if you read how alphago works it will
help you it will also help if i read the
the the
15 research
pages of research they they published
which i had intended to do i printed it
out and i was gonna i said to myself
okay this sounds very important you
really should read whatever is going on
here um
i did really do it i was more interested
in the chess games
themselves um yeah so this opposite
colored bishop end game pawn up but
alphago just won it
so easily uh
so i i assumed that he just
knew that the opposite colored bishop in
game was uh was winning
and uh well at this point probably even
i could could win it
uh and stockfish
resigned
okay i'm gonna find the um
uh cesar has some
some comments this is a large departure
from how every other successful engine
has worked before
there have been eight engines uh based
on the same principle
but none that are as good as stockfish
so that i just find very interesting
that we have
a new way of um
of coding um or
making chess engines
i i just use them i don't really know
how they're made
kind of like how i eat sausages
um
[Music]
yeah i'm going to go to the next game
i'm going to find out the next game i
want to look at
so this was a very nice strategic uh
black win from alpha 0. um
there are tons of extremely interesting
um
extremely interesting um
attacking wins uh
some of the most spectacular attacks you
have ever seen
um
but i'm gonna focus more on the
positional because
my thinking is this we already knew that
with uh extreme processing power
the computers are just insane at
attacking chess and tactics and and
mating the king and and so on and so
forth and and what i find uh more
interesting is the fact that alphago
seems to or this alpha zero uh seems to
um
kind of correct
some of the
positional mis-evaluations that
stockfish has had
so i'm going to
change
the game
uh to this one
uh and it's a french defense
uh with alpha zero
being uh white
and i think the first interesting thing
here is bishop d3
so naturally the bishop is better on d3
than on e2
but
the kind of human reason normally not to
play bishop d3 would be that you're
afraid of being
stormed on the queen side
and getting into trouble that way
and actually this bishop d3 is
interesting because it has been played
at the highest level quite recently
uh
by a certain mr gary kasparov
who i believe most chess players have
heard of
and
uh and and
yeah so alphago uh copies uh kasparov uh
that that's a nice headline uh anyway uh
kasparov playing against kharana uh
corona police b5
and in fact none
of the top level players having this
position with black has played c4
and this i think is one of the
uh positional mis-evaluations
stockfish has had for some time
and that's also why
humans are looking to get these
positions because
if their opponents only trust the engine
they might get to into a favorable
position so my hypothesis is that
stockfish in general
is
uh
underestimating the power of having
a static
pawn center
space advantage
and basically that's exactly what
alphago is
demonstrating
in uh
in this game so uh we see uh stockfish
with black going with the pawns trying
to attack on the queen side while um
alphago is doing the
king side attack
uh going f5 trying to weaken
this pawn chain
uh so instead of having to attack
f7
he can now attack e6 instead after
trading on e6 and it's easier to get
access to this e6 pawn
how do we get access well okay we could
get a knight to g5 so on and so forth
but there's an attack looming on the
queen side
uh and um
and so this move is
maybe easy
but it's brilliant still it's just
bishop d1 the only square the bishop
could move to without being captured
and it's just about getting the knight
over to the king side and also attacking
the pawn on e6
so b4 takes takes the knight comes
and
stockfish we see that the low depth
stockfish is evaluating about
0.3 in favor of white
but in reality probably it's much much
worse
and for instance let's take an example
variation
knight b6
c3
uh
but white just keeps his pawn chain
knowing that he has the space advantage
in the center
limiting his uh
opponent's options having more space to
maneuver behind his pawns trying to
generate an attack
against the black king
and if we kind of follow the the logical
continuation then
very soon uh
black is going to be in huge trouble so
i just checked this line with uh my own
computer
and basically after a little while it
started realizing that
the white attack
on the king's side
having a lot of pieces
uh ready to
contribute
in this attack
is just so much more powerful than
uh black
and kind of his attempt
at attacking the pawn
uh on on b2
um
so yeah uh already in the pawn structure
it's it's troubled some for black
and it seems to me that alpha zero
understood this pawn structure
better than
um than stockfish and i'm some of the
other games i'm going to go through is
also going to have the very same pawn
structure
and illustrate pretty much uh the same
point
so what happened here is that stockfish
made upon sacrifice in order to get his
pieces into play
the low stepped
low that stockfish is saying that okay
white is better but it's not a disaster
whereas what alphago demonstrated in the
game is that uh the important part here
is still
that the
white pawn shield is more aggressive uh
values uh the space advantage that white
has
high
bim bomb in the twitch chat is saying
that alpha is just flawless
and we might be close to the end of
chess development
um i'm not that much of a of a pessimist
i still thought that there were some
some strange decisions
uh made by alpha zero
um
and presumably if this is an alpha zero
version in which it has been training
for
what what they were saying that like
four hours
uh
it
seems reasonable to believe that
giving it
a bit more time to practice it would
become even stronger
and then it's also the question of
whether you can commercialize it whether
this can be used by
chess players for tournament chess
uh catch is asking do you think this
finding is in any way going to help make
chess
more
draw free
and um
i'm not sure but right this moment i
would say yes because right now alphago
has demonstrated a top level uh in which
it won 50
50 of its white games
uh it won against stockfish which was
previously basically regarded as
the truth
um and i think
uh some of the attacking games uh
we've seen in um
among the example games i think some of
the attacking games there is are
absolutely magnificent and i think it's
going to open up for some
some new opening uh theory developments
just based on what we know now um i'm
betting that uh there are people
analyzing the the queen's indian with d5
pawn sacrifices
uh because alpha alpha zero won like
three games in which it uh sacrificed a
pawn uh in which stockfish said no no
i'm completely fine and then he was just
completely
crushed off the board
um
so
right now i'm thinking
uh there's potential for for less straws
but on the other hand if everybody gets
the same stuff if everybody has
the same
uh help
uh from
their computer with this new software
uh then probably it's not gonna make too
much of a difference for for tournament
players
uh cesar is saying that deepmind is not
in the business of selling software
they're in the business of artificial
intelligence resource research
so it's very unlikely they'll try to
sell this
um
and that i agree with 100
but but that's also what makes
it interesting i think is
can we get
a version of
this software
for
laptops basically something tournament
players can use and
it's not at all certain that the answer
to that will be yes so it's a very
interesting development development in
terms of we've seen chess being played
at a higher level than we have ever seen
before
but we we might not get the luxury of
seeing
this amazing engine play
um so many um
so
so many chess games that we would like
okay um yeah i'm gonna try to go through
this game uh basically white got upon uh
kept his uh spatial advantage
and uh what's interesting is kind of how
it how it developed um because we got
some trades and essentially we got this
position
in which uh white is a pawn up but black
has the unopposed a light squared bishop
so it's not really at all clear
whether white will manage to strike the
to to
to
to get the win
um
but once again i think it's very
interesting to see how patient
uh
this alpha zero engine is
and it just very gradually
improved its position
and
managed
to um
create
a win
and i'm not going to spend too much time
on every single move
but kind of very gradually it builds its
advantage improves his king improves the
bishop improves the pawn the night
and then
at the opportune moment
it's uh
you know offering
offering stuff
if you want it
uh but also actually making progress
uh
and um
here
it
decides let's just give this pawn on c3
because it realizes that it has a plan
uh to get
the knight over to the other side
and uh
the the low depth stockfish is giving
point zero plus for white
and um
yeah just alpha zero i think was
completely sure it was going to win this
game at this point i i think
the the end game technique
uh
has been was very impressive especially
how patient
um
uh alphacera was in kind of gradually
improving pieces
and now when the
the rook comes over
on the
the king side
yeah
i don't remember the game exactly but
basically we had the same position
earlier with the rook on c3
instead of uh of f7
and it's gone
ten moves and it's not really looking
like alpha zero is doing anything
special
um
but then suddenly uh he sits with a
knight on c5
which looks pretty good with the king
that can go up to
g6
the bishop being locked
on c8 dominated by the white knight
and
yeah
and then just going into a rook end game
in which it it knew it was going to win
and i mean in terms of kind of the best
play
uh
even here stockfish is saying this is
winning for white it's saying go king g4
and basically there's nothing black can
do but instead
alphago allows this g6 resource which
which kind of was supposed to prolong
the game
um
and i i don't know um
stockfish is saying it was a mistake to
allow this g6 thing but on the other
hand it's not like white was ever in
danger of not winning the game it took
forever
in terms of it's been 40 moves since we
had this position
and it's not like it it looked like
there was too much more progress he
needed to do
uh but but 40 moves later he's still
very patient
gradually taking all the pawns
uh
and then at some point you know starfish
just realizes that these pawns i'm not
gonna stop
but
still alphago is going very much back
and forth i mean here having this
maneuver of going with the king and then
back to d4
it's very hard for me to believe that
that is the quickest route
to win
but i can on the other hand i can easily
believe that it's a route to win
so um
i'm not sure it's flawless if it is
flawless then it's just
on a level beyond uh human understanding
because some of these maneuvers in what
was
otherwise easily winning positions
uh is is just insane
yeah
it doesn't care how much the advantage
is it only cares that it's winning
so uh it's patient and it's
cumbersome in some ways in getting the
the wind
yeah and uh chess player in the chess tv
chat
is saying it would be funny to see all
the mistakes stockfish
uh catches from alpha zero uh and i mean
i played through the games with my own
stockfish engine and
certainly stockfish did think that
some of the moves from from alphago were
not the best ones
partially because of course they have a
difference of opinion that's how alpha
zero managed to win so many games
it has to mean that they differ in
opinion that alphago believes something
is good for him while um
while stockfish
thinks he's okay
and that's actually gonna be our next
example
uh a game
sorry
a game in which
um
alphago alpha zero is
just
out outplaying
the guy when stockfish thought he was
doing okay
okay so this is the next one
kasper is asking does your stockfish
have 64 cores
and that is a big big no
from me
so i i understand that my stock fish is
not at the level of the stock fish that
was used uh
in the uh experiment
uh but i still i mean it's based on the
same code so i think it's interesting to
to
to compare anyhow
uh okay i'm gonna
basics is asking how much did your
stockfish agree or disagree with the
stockfish moves
and that's
just as interesting
i guess but
as was the point that was made earlier
is that my stockfish is not as strong
as the stock fish that was used
for these games
so it could be that there are things
that
the the stock fish playing alpha zero
understood which my stockfish was just
not strong enough to understand
uh okay i'm gonna
i think this is maybe
the the most uh it's the second most
interesting game i think
at least of the positional ones i'm
gonna fast forward to this position
uh which is very interesting but it's
the same theme that i was talking about
earlier it's about the advanced uh pawn
on e5 having the
central space advantage and using it to
develop a king an attack
against the black king
and as you may notice
in this example that has come at a cost
so there's a pawn an extra pawn
on
c4
or maybe i should say there's an extra
pawn on c6 because otherwise
other than that the the position is
basically symmetrical
um
and then some would actually say that
well black would be better off without
this pawn because right now it's
massively blocking the bishop on
b7 and i think that's another thing i
noticed in these example games uh is
that this bishop on b7 black's a light
squared bishop was really having a
miserable time uh when playing
the alphago
the alpha zero
uh and uh initially my stockfish is
giving minus 0.6
here in
in black's favor
but it gradually drops to about minus um
0.38
but
minus 0.38 is still
black advantage so in this position
stockfish thinks it's better with black
and then gradually as you go deeper when
when you just enter the moves
as they were played they are all top
choices of the computer
and at this point
uh
the the computer kind of
starts out thinking that
black is still better
but now after thinking for a while it
drops to zero
so after thinking for a while here the
computer is saying okay maybe maybe it's
equal
but it's still not saying that it's
better for white
and that's what alphago managed to to do
is that he won this
with white
making it look like a complete genius
so the big question here is whether or
not to play h5 and i think from a human
perspective
probably we would play h5
and that means that it's
interesting to see
what
um
how alphago would have proceeded with
against h5 so
you you would think that probably you
want to do something like
queen f3 and try to play g4 and say that
put playing this pawn out has weakened
the g6 square and
maybe it's easier to attack the king
but but it's still a very tricky
position
i'm going to say white is better
by the reasoning that
alphago won a very alpha zero won a very
similar position but i would be
i actually think it's a pity that
stockfish didn't play h5 because i think
from a human perspective it's more easy
to understand what happened in the game
after bishop hf8 because what
um
alphago did here alpha zero
uh what he did was that he played h5
naturally and then he put his queen on
the h-pot
queen f6 is very nice saying that if you
take this queen then both your bishops
are basically being
running out of moves
so
black cannot really take this queen
and we end up
with uh
white
getting a slightly improved pawn
structure having now the attacking
target on
e6
uh
stockfish still thinks it's equal it's
saying
0.00 it thinks okay well
i'm not that concerned
and then
alphago plays this move
bishop b2 and then my engine goes from
saying zero zero zero to going complete
uh completely nuts
and it very quickly it goes up to 0.5
in white's favor and just by watching
this
64 core
stockfish engine
after this bishop c1 move presumably
getting the bishop up
in an attacking position
uh the 64 stockfish uh
course goes c3 which is just so clearly
desperation it's so clear that it has
seen something in the future if you just
make the normal moves it's going to be a
disaster so it plays c3 to kind of
distract white on the other side of the
board but the thing is that after c3
even a human can win this position
because you realize that well now i have
all the other good stuff
in addition i'm taking
i'm taking your pawn
so the kind of the advantage you had of
being a pawn up has disappeared you
still have the open age file the bad
pawn structure the um
space advantage for white
um
and and um
and i'll forgo just one in big style
and look at the bishop on b7 it's just
it's having a miserable time
and we get another end game but but an
endgame even stockfish acknowledges that
this is just
not gonna happen
this is massively better for white
yeah i'm not sure why he would give back
that pawn but
yeah everything just collapses
and two pawns up is going to be enough
to win the game
uh i'm wondering is the twitch chat
is the twitch chat discussing fortresses
because that is interesting
i'm gonna have to take a drink
yeah that's interesting
from from a just
intuitively i would think that
fortresses aren't
it might be discovered much easier by
alphago if it's going by a simulation
and
giving itself
wind percentages instead of
yeah it's gonna it's gonna understand
fortresses maybe
um
nylock is asking did they publish more
than just 10 games
and that is no
um
they are saying that they are kind of
withholding a bit until they get the
uh the paper the full paper uh published
uh so there's gonna be a lot of more
interesting chess to
analyze uh as um
as the weeks um
in the next weeks i hope
okay so ship homer is saying you're
discussing trapped pieces and the way
they're evaluated in regular engines and
this bishop on b7 being a perfect
example of
a trapped piece
and that there might be some search
problems
with those positions
that yeah the stockfish maybe doesn't
appreciate how bad the bishop is on
uh
on uh
on b7 but on the other hand i would
think that is
something at least an algorithm could
cover right that if a bishop is blocked
by its own pawns it should be massively
punished
um yeah i'm gonna go to the to the next
game because i saved the best for last
yeah
i think this is my favorite game
uh it's a lot of the same themes
as
the the other games
okay so
once again it's a positional play that
caught my fancy it's a french defense
and this is kind of the starting uh pawn
structure
definitely uh favoring white
uh having the uh
familiar
uh e5 d4
french structure
which we also saw earlier
and the bishop on c8
not having a good time
and stockfish went into this
stockfish went into it i mean he
realizes even stockfish realizes that
white is a little bit better here but
he's giving evaluations like 0.2
favoring white and probably those
evaluations are just plain wrong
um so stockfish even got his opponent's
bishop
but uh alphago doesn't care he just
puts his king on e3
uh helping out his uh central pawns
uh stockfish none the wiser still saying
point 10
and now we get the attack going
white goes g4
would go f5 if he was allowed stockfish
is um
saying that i'm pretty solid i'll just
play my bishop back to f8
it's difficult for you to find any
uh point to attack
and now he also has the open uh h pile
so he's not really reliant on
castling to get the um the work into
play
uh yeah so uh
my stockfish is saying 0.00 here
here it starts realizing that white is
um
a bit better
but on the other hand banach is solid he
has the bishop pair uh
he has pawns protecting each other
seemingly there's
there's not too much of an issue
um
and this is there was a comment made on
twitter which which i think relates very
nicely to this game which is strategy
is just
deep deep tactics
so strategy is basically getting a good
position in which tactics are going to
work
i think that is even an old uh
a saying of the old masters
that
good strategy
gives you good tactical options later on
and um
and this is an example of that uh black
seemingly very solid very difficult to
break down
and then we have the most amazing tactic
striking down
so this position after knight g5
you can go
bishop h6 you can go
bishop e7 it doesn't really matter
because after bishop e7
alphago played
bishop takes g6
and i mean this is this is a display of
the amazing tactical ability of alphago
um but it's not really
the attacking chess that a lot of the
games that i have ignored
uh has
uh this is more kind of deep strategy
and then breaking through
uh the barriers with amazing tactical
play
so so white has achieved uh an
advantageous position
uh a position where stockfish doesn't
really realize the danger
including right now because you know
stockfish is evaluating it at um
0.05
uh but the big point here
after sacrificing
a piece for a pawn
um
and then he goes f5
this is the the tactical justification
so
if
if g takes there's an instant check
and
the rook comes to win the day
if you take with the e pawn it's similar
because the queen
uh gets access to the uh
the d6 square to the b6 pawn
basically it's big big trouble
so black is forced to play rook g8
and now the point is
after queen h6
threatening
checkmate
queen f7 and then f6
it's a pawn for a bishop
but on the other hand
this bishop on b7
not really the greatest piece you've
seen
and um
initially i i let my stockfish run for
maybe two three minutes
uh it says 0.00
for a very long time
but it drops massively
during the
the next couple of moves
um and the key here is that why
why is seemingly just playing on normal
moves right
rook c1 how do you explain rook c1 to
somebody
and this is also my point of of the the
engine being extremely patient
so i think i think what happened is that
the king had to move back because it
wanted to give the queen the option of
going using the e3 square
and so
in this position you want the rook to
have access to go to the g file whenever
you want
so you go rook c1
and black
really cannot do anything he he's stuck
he cannot really improve his bishop
um
or his rook or or queen
the the pawn on on on f6 is really a
thorn
uh and what happens here is queen e3
and my computer goes from saying
0.00 to just
very quickly dropping to to plus one
for white
um
and then kind of when it realizes that
the i i think the plan here is to go to
to a3 forcing queen f8 and then just
exchanging the queens
i think is i think white spine in this
position is to exchange queens and win
the end game come with the king
attacking
uh up towards the g6 pawn um
so black plays queen f8 to stop it but
then queen c3 is threatening mate on on
c7 if you go back to f7 then once again
there's this idea of the queen getting
in via a3 so he goes queen b4 but then
kind of white gets his
uh
queen exchange
and uh
here the even stock fish realizes that
it's big big trouble
my stock fish started at plus one
and then pretty quickly came up to plus
two
uh
and at this point it's already at plus
five
um
so two pawns for a bishop
that's all you need
so the bishop comes back alive uh to e8
stopping the f6 pawn protecting the
g6 pawn
you would think that that was uh
that was a good thing but the thing is
that suddenly white is just opening
another flank of attack
uh on the other side
uh with the rook coming on the uh a file
and then the king
coming over to help
queen
the
the f-pawn
and uh
the bishop is defenseless against uh
this invasion
so um yeah
uh these were the uh positional games i
would say of alpha zero um
and which i thought were really really
interesting i thought they
um
there was some kind of position in which
uh stockfish uh misevaluated uh what was
going on and was punished very severely
uh for it
uh i you really i really recommend
looking through all 10 games that were
published
among the games i didn't look at were
some amazing uh attacking chess
sacrificing a piece and basically not
caring just to keep developing for four
moves afterwards
um
some fantastic attacking chess
from alphago
and i think a lot of people will say
that this was not a fair match
i'm inclined to agree
i i think that probably
um
[Music]
the hardware difference was pretty
significant and so on
so i don't think it was a fair match but
i do think that we have never seen chess
being played at a higher level than what
alpha zero accomplished
and um
that is after all i think the most
important part
uh that um
that alphago alpha zero is kind of
opening our eyes to
some
misconceptions
basically stockfish has been has been
the
the answer i mean if we were saying what
is the objective evaluation of a
position we would often go to stockfish
and what has happened
uh this week is that
stockfish is no longer the answer we we
need to appreciate that
there are even attacking positions
stockfish is the most amazing attacker
[Music]
as an engine stockfish is just
magnificent at attacking and yet even so
it got crushed uh in some tactical uh
[Music]
skimmerishes
uh against um alpha zero
uh and and i think that's an
illustration of uh just a new level we
have never seen before
it's going to challenge
our idea of some positions maybe we are
going to be
more
aggressive i don't know
but i think it's a good sign that
stockfish underestimates
uh some of the attacking chess from
alpha zero because that means that
maybe we can be a bit more crazy maybe
we can be
a bit more aggressive in our
normal games
with the justification from the computer
and not kind of always
saying
yeah it looks interesting but stockfish
is giving minus 0.8
we should stay away
um
yeah
and i also think that that alpha 0 seems
to have
some positional understanding that uh
stockfish has been lacking and and i
hope these games have um been an
introduction to to why
uh and we have seen the the black light
squared bishop suffering quite a few
games and i think this
static pawn structure with d4 e5
is going to be
be valued
okay um i'm gonna be looking at the the
chats for a little while so if you have
a question this is the time
uh to do it and after that i'm
i'm gonna say
good night
grandillo is saying that even at his
level
alpha zero has inspired him to be
to be more
crazy
[Music]
shana i'm gonna say shorten it will all
the games be available soon
and that is a big question i don't have
the answer i hope so
uh because
analyzing those games will be really
really interesting
so
nobody knows well probably somebody at
google knows
uh but we're all hoping that um
as many games as possible will be
available
uh
medutes is asking could it find shiro's
bishop h3 and i would just say that the
way it played in games was just superb
so i'm gonna say it would find bishop h3
without any problem
uh alpha zero does it use regular
opening book no
it kind of taught itself openings so
it's using some sort of opening book
based on
uh what it taught itself uh
at the beginning
at the beginning of its learning process
uh here's an interesting question from
nsky
do you think alpha zero favoring d4 c4
will change how the opening is viewed
that's very interesting
and and yeah just the fact that alpha
zero is favoring d4 or at least has
uh all
almost exclusively the white winds we
were presented
uh were was d4
uh
so um
yeah i'm thinking that uh the the
gambits in the queen's indian
uh is going to get some scrutiny
scrutinizing
the next couple of months because alpha
0 had some very nice wins in in that
opening
bononi is asking what was its main
weapon against e4 and i'm happy to say
that that was the berlin
my opening berlin was favored by alphago
chessbar is asking
do you think alpha's self-taught
openings or self-taught end games
are more impressive for four hours
um
i don't know
it really only spent four hours i didn't
really quite understand that
uh i was reading the kind of paper and
it was saying giving a lot of
interesting stats about the openings it
had played in the training games
so that i thought was very fascinating
um
yeah but i i i don't really understand
how it works well enough to say
what what i i think just the general
level of play i was extremely impressed
by
catch is asking is there any chances of
some defenses to become obsolete
um
maybe
um the you really should check out the
the the paper they published um
just a partial paper or something
um
and there were some openings which
alphago
the the alpha zero tried
to use and then kind of gradually
decided that no this is no good i will i
will uh
not play this opening as often
so basically it was playing queens
gambit declined it was playing quite a
bit
but but grunfeld and king's indian it
was
not playing
with the black pieces
i thought
bar is how you pronounce b-a-e
just ba
no
um
feinman is asking what kind of style do
you think alpha
alpha zero has
um and he adds perfection maybe has no
style
um
yeah
no it's it's just very good it's a
fantastic attacker it's profound
positional play
it's it's just very impressive very
impressive
okay
i think my voice is saying that's it for
me today
um
thank you for uh checking out
uh my stream today
um
i'm
gonna say that this is not the last we
have heard from
uh
from the the alpha zero engine uh so i'm
i'm gonna have more streams uh on this
when uh we get more games published i i
think that's
a fair bet
so
until next time
see ya
you